الصين ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم تواجه
رياحا معاكسه مع نهايه عام 2022 حيث وصل
النمو في البلاد الى ادنى مستوياته في وقت
تراجع فيه عدد السكان للمره الاولى منذ
نحو سته عقود في تفاصيل الارقام حقق
الاقتصاد الصيني نموا بنسبه ثلاثه بالمئه
في عام 2022 وفق المكتب الوطني للاحصاء
مسجلا ادنى معدلاته خلال 40 عاما بسبب
تفشي فيروس كورونا والازمه العقاريه التي
شهدتها البلاد تمثل هذه الارقام اسوا نمو
الصين منذ عام
1976 وكان لمشاكل الصين الاقتصاديه العام
الماضي ارتدادات انعكست على سلاسل التوريد
العالميه التي لا تزال تعاني تزال تعاني
منها حاليا مع تراجع الطلب مش عايزين
نتوقع على البنك الدولي ان ينتعش الانتاج
والناتج المحلي الاجمالي للصين الى
4.3% عام 20
20 لكنه رغم ذلك لا يزال اقل من التوقعات
الاقتصاديه على صعيد اخر تراجع عدد سكان
الصين خلال العام الماضي للمره الاولى منذ
نحو سته عقود حيث تلوح في الافق ازمه
ديموغرافيه تهدد اكبر دوله في العالم من
ناحيه عدد السكان هذا وشاهدت الدوله التي
يبلغ عدد سكانها واحد فصل 4 مليار نسمه
انخفاضا في معدل الولادات الى مستويات
قياسيه ترافق مع تقدم قوتها العامله في
العمر الصين مشاهدينا انهت الف عام 2016
سياسه الطفل الواحد التي فرضتها في
الثمانيات بسبب مخاوف من زياده سكانيه
هائله وعام 2021 بدات بالسماح للازواج
بانجاب ثلاثه اطفال
[موسيقى]